the ship really fires me up this right
here video my eyes are talking about how
I randomly say what's up to people
and give love it's something I do a ton
of and it will never get old like
literally sitting there on a flight and
hitting up six people 12 people and just
saying keep doing what you're doing of
people that I'm observing or my team's
observing is moving in the right ways
making happen the encouragement
that you can give kids on the come up
especially when you've achieved a little
something where they take that love that
you're giving them and actually really
appreciate it you know I wish I grew up
in this era where my business or pop
culture or entertainment
Heroes could just stop and give love
most people are just not given enough
love people's finding time to leave
and hate on people's things but I think
for a lot of leaders you spend more time
just hitting up random
kids on the come up and give them love